my name is Tom Burchard I'm the proud
owner of the selca restaurant in the
corner of second Avenue in night's room
a pierogi
is an Eastern European dumpling made
with a simple dough wrapper wrapped
around a simple feeling it could be a
potato of meat cabbage cheese
well it's the Eastern European
equivalent of a ravioli or a Chinese
dumpling I think every culture has some
form of dumpling they're known for
we're known preparing the pierogies
recipe goes back to when I first came
here in the 60s the process starts with
making a very large fat of dough similar
to pizza dough and we run it through a
machine called a sheeter that rolls it
out into a fairly thin sheet and we take
that sheet put it on a table and they
cut a lot of discs we're left with a
whole table full of these discs and then
they put the stuffing in by hand then
each one is lovingly crimped by hand
that's where most of the labor comes in
we make two to three thousand a day so
it's a lot of ham would they have to be
boiled to seal them but they're not
completely cooked they're then cooled
and packed in containers and held and so
they come upstairs for final preparation
which involves another boiling or frying
until they're tender and then they're
served with sour cream and sauteed
onions some people like apple sauce
that's not traditional but sour cream
and
required pierogies are both Polish and
Ukrainian that part of Western Ukraine
was governed by several different
political groups so what we call
Ukrainian food other people would call a
Polish food some people call it Jewish
food sometimes I'd describe it as
peasant food all those things are true
this is Eastern European food cooking
that's really really well known and
loved in New York and once some people
around the country but over the years he
have been concerned that this was zine
this food would fall out of favor
eventually but honestly the opposite has
happened that seems to be getting more
popular non Eastern Europeans or mine
Jewish people really feel an affinity
for this food so that's very gratifying
to me to kind of satisfy that yearning
for grandma's coding